[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radio Francia internacional y de
France 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
los planes europeos ante la crisis
energética que vive el continente para
ello nos acompañan en este estudio
eusebio balco responsable del diario La
Vanguardia bienvenido Hola buenos días
Beatriz juez corresponsal del diario el
correo bienvenida y Yago del barrio
experto en ingeniería energética de
samspo aquí en París bienvenido Muchas
gracias los planes europeos Francia
entre ellos con su escudo energético
para capear la crisis energética hoy
nuestro asunto en Primera Plana
[Música]
lo estamos viendo estos días las grandes
economías sacan la chequera para
amortiguar el golpe de la inflación y la
crisis energética los gobiernos europeos
ensayan distintas políticas Fiscales
para hacer frente a los efectos de la
escalada de precios en ciudadanos y
empresas Alemania con un ambicioso plan
de 200.000 millones de euros criticado
por varios países de su entorno otros
como Italia bajando cotizaciones otros
subiendos impuestos a los ricos como el
caso de Países Bajos y Francia que
parece que logra contener la inflación
mejor que el resto de sus Socios con su
llamado escudo energético veremos y
también le sirve a macron para capear
las tensiones sociales en otoño y evitar
ese otoño caliente en el que ya planea
una de las reformas estrellas del
quinquenio la de las pensiones repasemos
algunas portadas de prensa diario de
París y a un titular como reducir su
factura de la electricidad la obsesión
ciudadana ahora mismo el Alemán sudeche
saitun titula contra el frío al lado de
un calentador en bolsa de los que usaban
nuestras abuelas el diario en este
artículo se pregunta si esta situación
es un Punto de partida para un otoño
caliente para macron en esta situación
Lemon esta semana se hacía Eco del
estudio fracturas francesas para titular
Francia sigue descontenta pero baja la
crispación y aumenta el nivel de
confianza en el sistema de líneas
generales en medio de esta crisis luego
vamos a comentarlo también en el
programa bueno en serio está
consiguiendo Europa capear por el
momento con sus planes con sus escudos
energéticos los estallidos sociales esos
que pretendía Putin yo creo que de
momento Sí cada país a su manera cada
país con medidas diferenciadas y aparte
con una coordinación a nivel europeo yo
creo que la política de momento está
funcionando pero el potencial de
descontento está ahí en países por
ejemplo como Francia con gran tradición
de reivindicativa y de protestas pero de
momento si Putin confiaba en que eso iba
a
beneficiarle yo creo que el momento no
porque hay otros factores como la ayuda
militar masiva a Ucrania que están
teniendo un impacto muy fuerte es decir
que yo creo que de momento por ese lado
energético
está resistiendo Europa claro con ese
elemento de descontento en las opiniones
públicas occidentales para que le
sirvieran en la guerra pero sin embargo
por el momento 61 sociales los consigue
campear Europa con estos planes de los
que hablamos
la ministra de transición ecológica
francesa decía que Putin usa el gas como
un arma de guerra no un arma más igual
que los tanques y y por ahora de momento
yo creo que también Hemos llegado al
invierno crudo era de momento no sé cómo
era la calefacción
no hay cortes una vez que lleguemos en
invierno a lo mejor en diciembre y justo
que cuando está hablándose la reforma de
las pensiones según un poco todo que no
Tienen calefacción que le quiere que
quieren que trabaje más tiempo y todo
eso a lo mejor ahí está ya no yo creo
que de momento como ha pasado el verano
tampoco la gente lo ha notado habrá
notado la cartera pero no lo ha notado
tanto físicamente no Y además la
perspectiva de la guerra es que va a
durar vale desgraciadamente no se va a
acabar mañana la crisis energética sigue
golpeando con fuerza ante el temor de un
corte energético provocado por Rusia
como decía Beatriz los países siguen
actuando e implantando medidas para el
ahorro energético y la pregunta ya hago
Cómo se construye un plan de sobriedad
qué tipos de medidas se deben
privilegiar luego vamos a ver lo que ha
hecho el caso francés que fue anunciado
este jueves cuéntanos pues para realizar
un buen plan de seguridad es necesario
no inventar la rueda simplemente seguir
los las indicaciones que ya se recogen
desde autoridades comunitarias y desde
todos los países reducir las
temperaturas de las calefacciones
intentar no malgastar luz básicamente
son medidas de eficiencia energética
intentar reducir un consumo superfluo de
electricidad y de gas y es que según ha
anunciado el gobierno francés Con este
plan de seguridad que no es ninguna
locura son medidas simples y fáciles de
cumplir puedes llegar a ahorrar un 10%
del consumo de energía que son precios
se puede traducir en una bajada
significativa entonces no es inventar la
rueda Es simplemente seguir las medidas
ya existentes que llevan años intentando
implantarse pero que hay mucha
resistencia y mucha vida inercia en
contra la pregunta es si vale solo con
la voluntariedad O con la incitación o
hay que pasar a un grado superior o si
vamos a tener también el reflejo de lo
que pasó con la crisis sanitaria No
claro de Siempre en un principio lo que
se intenta Es que la población siga de
estas estas directivas pero es verdad
que muchas veces al haber tanta
resistencia acaban imponiéndose entonces
es posible que se pase de las
recomendaciones existentes actualmente a
imposiciones en temperaturas máximas y
medidas bastante bastante más estrictas
que las existentes yo creo que depende
de cómo evoluciones depende de las
temperaturas de este invierno y Depende
cómo del suministro pasaremos de
recomendaciones como las existentes a
medidas bastante más duras Por cierto
que las reservas Francia ya ha anunciado
que sus reservas de gas llegan al 100% y
de media en la Unión Europea está en el
89 que son cifras bastante buenas por el
momento
vamos a llegar a la coerción o nos vamos
a quedar en el en el nivel más bajo en
la incitación
Yo creo que por una parte estas medidas
de limitación de precios tanto a nivel
europeo como de todos los gobiernos Es
natural que se apliquen para amortiguar
los efectos sobre la población pero
claro por otro lado si la gente no se
rasca el bolsillo sino ve que los
precios realmente suben mucho y le
afectan pues su comportamiento en el
terreno energético no va a variar es
decir que es un arma de doble filo No
que los gobiernos por motivos políticos
la aplican pero si la gente no lo nota
pasa como cuando los chalecos amarillos
que la revuelta el detona fue un aumento
mínimo del precio del carburante con la
ecotasa Y entonces se armó una casi una
Revolución es decir que
la población A menos aquí en Francia es
muy sensible a al aumento de precios y
solo con recomendaciones yo me Temo que
el efecto no va a ser muy muy grande
como no recuerda esta situación a la
vivida en la pandemia verdad
hay un cierto es paralelismos no esto
Esto no suena de antes no sí es como
ayer también anunciaron que van a
empezar a publicar todos los precios de
los precios del gas y la electricidad
que cada y va a salir una vez a la
semana al gobierno anunciando los
precios y me recordó Justo a todos los
días durante la pandemia que estamos
siguiendo cada día si subían o no subían
los números de infectados el número de
muertos y yo creo que este invierno va a
pasar otra vez también lo mismo que
estaremos estarán todos los días en la
televisión diciendo Sube sube la
electricidad y todo eso también va a
crear A lo mejor quizá un estallido
social que aquí en Francia como dice
eusebio protestar es casi el deporte
nacional no Por cierto yo hago con estos
niveles de reservas que en el caso de
Francia llega al 100% la media europea
en el 89 El fantasma de los recortes del
suministro se aleja sería día digamos el
último recurso efectivamente siempre ha
sido el último recurso pero hay que
tener en cuenta que un 100% de reservas
a nivel comunitario no da para más de un
30% del consumo anual y en invierno
en los países del sur no Estamos tan
acostumbrados pero los países más
nórdicos con temperaturas tan extremas
aunque tengas una reserva de un 30% del
año no te da para pasar todo el invierno
porque es cuando más se consume entonces
va a depender del suministro de otros
países el poder llegar a esos cortes
pero yo creo que la comisión y tanto los
estados miembros llevan un plan bastante
contundente para intentar evitar ese
escenario que sería el último el último
recurso ideas esto que dijo la comisión
de regulación de la energía que en
Francia esta semana que pueda haber
situaciones de tensión en función del
consumo en los próximos meses es cierto
es decir pese a tener la reservas sí que
se puede llegar a cortes de suministro
que otra cosa sería Cómo se van a
aplicar en un país no acostumbrado Esto
no es latinoamérica claro efectivamente
sería el último escenario pero sí que se
va a tensionar mucho el sistema
si conseguimos reducir el consumo
de hecho de aquí tanto interés en estos
planes de seguridad porque si se
consigue reducir Y no tensionar y llevar
a estos extremos Se va a poder evitar
los cortes de todas formas esto es como
lo que ha dicho vea en función de lo que
pasa cada semana y de los reportes
semanales seguirá viendo y la comisión
ir a irá tomando decisiones y de hecho
el gobierno francés va a publicar la
cifra total de consumo energético
nacional en lo que parece una especie de
examen colectivo a la nación es decir es
trasladar un poco al ciudadano una
especie de responsabilidad colectiva y
vamos a combinándonos semana a semana no
sé cómo lo ven esa estrategia del
gobierno Porque al fin al cabo es una
especie de estrategia no y lo que pasa
que aquí en Francia yo creo que se está
escamoteando en parte el debate el
debate sobre todo sobre la electricidad
no porque una cosa es el gas y otra es
la electricidad y aquí Francia tiene el
problema añadido de de sus centrales
nucleares que casi por orgullo nacional
se habla pero no demasiado de un
programa gravísimo que más de la mitad
de las centrales está en para los
reactores están parados por
mantenimiento o por problemas de fisuras
problemas técnicos graves no O sea que
se suma la crisis ucraniana y este
problema interno de descuido de fin de
de una planificación
errónea de todo el sector nuclear
francés
que en Francia mucha gente tiene
calefacción eléctrica y todo eso bueno
y la electricidad depende también mucho
de las de la energía nuclear No aquí en
Francia es la gran
los gobiernos a todo esto preparan la
otra herramienta a su alcance que es la
política fiscal cada día Bueno estamos
viendo nuevos anuncios de descuentos
Fiscales o cambios impositivos en España
vemos una guerra autonómica por bajar
tramos del impuesto de la renta y en
este contexto se están produciendo Bueno
pues también situaciones como la del
Reino Unido de ir marcha atrás con la
bajada impositiva anunciada por lestras
porque no hay dinero en la caja entonces
para hacer frente a un mayor gasto bajar
impuestos y mantener el gasto Pero esto
es soplar y absorber al mismo tiempo que
es imposible es decir lo que no se puede
decir al ciudadano es que se pueden
bajar impuestos si se quiere mantener el
gasto eso es una cosa obvia pero a veces
no tienen una tentación de hacer estos
equilibrios imposibles
es muy para es muy significativo y muy
locuadro que le ha pasado al is tras
estos días en este sentido no lo creen
Sí pero es una situación en el Reino
Unido también muy particular de un
Primer Ministro que parecía que era muy
fuerte en el inicio y después pues los
programas que tuvo cayó con una
perspectiva de elecciones aquí al menos
macron tiene una perspectiva de casi 5
años gobernando no que en teoría debería
dar más estabilidad y estar menos
tentado a ciertas medidas digamos
populistas o que no se sostengan
presupuestariamente pero aún así para
evitar el descontento social existe la
tentación
Quizá lo tiene un poco más más fácil no
Bueno más fácil como siempre es
complicada aquí en Francia con Y bueno
ya veremos al final que es lo que pasa
pero pero sin Inglaterra es la verdad es
que la entrada de ilustración ha sido un
desastre total
vamos a hacer en este punto una breve
pausa y en unos instantes seguimos
analizando el plan de seguridad
introducimos además otro elemento la
reforma de las pensiones se da vuelta de
pausa aquí en Primera Plana hasta ahora
[Música]
Enlace del cono Sur a Norteamérica de
los Andes a Centroamérica una cita
semanal con los temas más importantes de
los países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
France 24
enlace en francés 24 y France 24.com
[Música]
Bienvenidos a las noticias de france24
hojas bien rechazo
[Música]
casi 99 millones de ustedes nos siguen
cada semana en france24 gracias
muchas gracias Su Gran área
sarajevo Managua Bali ciudades que como
tantas otras han sufrido la guerra el
hambre La dictadura o catástrofes
naturales
fukushima grossing la Habana France 24
vuelve a las regiones que marcaron la
actualidad internacional
sus habitantes cuentan su nueva vida sus
esperanzas y su lucha para superar un
pasado traumático
boleto de vuelta toda la semana por
France 24 y France 24.com
Seguimos aquí en Primera Plana esta
semana hablando de los planes de
sobriedad de los gobiernos europeos para
hacer frente de la crisis energética y
como esto de momento por el momento está
evitando estallido sociales en Europa lo
hacemos con eusebio Val Beatriz juez
periodistas y Yago del barrio experto en
energía en ingeniería energética de
senspo en París aquí en Francia de
momento la inflación está siendo
controlada en esta grave crisis de
subida de precios está alrededor del 6%.
gracias al llamado escudo energético
Yago En qué consiste ese escudo
energético que está consiguiendo que
está propiciando que Francia no tenga
unas tasas de inflación como el resto de
socios europeos este escudo energético
fue una medida que se tomó previa a la
guerra porque recordemos que se tomó en
2021 y consiste en mantener los precios
regulados tanto de la electricidad como
del gas a los niveles de octubre de 2021
Es verdad que la electricidad subió un
4% en febrero Pero eso mantener los
precios entonces claro el consumidor no
nota en su bolsillo la subida de precios
del mercado mayorista y recientemente
has anunciado que se va a ampliar a 2023
pero para que la gente Note de verdad el
cambio y la sube de precios la intención
es aumentar un 15% el coste de las
tarifas tanto la regulada para
electricidad como la regulada para el
gas a partir de 2023 McDonald Llegará el
poder en 2017 dijo que una de sus líneas
rojas era no subir impuestos de forma
general como compensar la deuda entonces
y aquí es donde hay que hablar de las
reformas que vienen Porque si su línea
roja no subir impuestos
Pues
de algún lado sí Bueno estamos diciendo
sorber y absorber el mismo tipo no es
posible que la reducir partidas del
presupuesto es muy difícil reducir
gastos sociales muy difícil educación el
tema militar
la situación en Europa exige más
inversiones y ahí llega la agenda de
reformas y llega la agenda de reformas
con la reforma de las pensiones que es
el gran el gran asunto de los próximos
meses creen que la reforma de las
pensiones es lo que va a marcar el
segundo quinquenio de macron es digamos
lo que va a definir el éxito o el
fracaso incluso la historia de lo que ha
sido una presidencia tanto podríamos
decir tanto durante la primer quinquenio
no logró hacerla sin y era su una de sus
de sus reformas estrellas Lo que me
llaman aquí la madre de todas las de
todas las reformas
que si no lo consigue esta vez yo creo
que sí que sería fracaso para para él
porque bueno los franceses empeñan en
que hay que no quieren trabajar más allá
de los 62 años pero
se necesita cada vez la gente bien más
tiempo hay menos niños y Alguien tiene
que pagar esas pensiones y por lo que
tienen que trabajar más tiempo que es lo
que quiere que macron hacer pero bueno
ya veremos Si lo consigue o no esta vez
y muchas veces de los que nos ven y nos
escucha Seguramente se pregunten por qué
tanta resistencia en un país como
Francia si tiene la edad de jubilación
más baja de la Unión Europea que les
podríamos responder sociológicamente
sorprendente que aquí en Francia haya
esta resistencia cuando países
económicamente más potentes como
Alemania pues
la están haciendo la ha hecho Italia la
han hecho los países escandinavos España
pero yo creo que en este país realmente
hay todavía una filosofía en ciertas
capas de la sociedad no que se pongo
como los años 70 80 donde se espera
mucho del Estado
es un Es realmente paradójico porque es
muy necesario hacerlo pero hay una
resistencia social muy fuerte y coincido
con lo que decía Beatriz que sí macrón
no lo no consigue llevarlo adelante
quedará una su presidencia por motivos
que no no son culpa suyas como la
pandemia o la o ahora la guerra pero
quedará muy descafeinada no sin el gran
el gran presidente transformador al
final no habrá conseguido prácticamente
ningún cambio significativo en la
sociedad de este país es decir que se
juega se juega un poco su legado ya no
su reelección no se la juega pero sí se
juega su legado como presidente de la
república cosa que para Él seguramente
sea muy importante en el caso de macron
de mirar cómo pasa a la historia lo que
está claro que tampoco son las mismas
las condiciones en las que representaba
su reforma de las pensiones en el primer
quinquenio cuando hubo también el
estallido de los chalecos amarillos que
una legitimidad que ahora acaba de pasar
por las urnas y la gente sabía que había
una reforma de las pensiones cómo lo ven
también del otro lado no tiene la
mayoría parlamentaria en la asamblea
nacional cierto es sí pienso que que
aquí siempre es difícil hacer cualquier
tipo de reforma y los franceses se
resisten bastante y les encanta
protestar por cualquier cosa Entonces es
cierto
bastante cierto y entonces no sé ya
veremos a ver cómo lo consigue hacer
ahora ha amenazado con disolver la
asamblea nacional
veremos un poco a ver es un poco un
juego también político no A ver quién es
el más fuerte de quién consigue hacerlo
ya veremos al final qué pasa No yo creo
que también en la discusión O sea yo
creo que la discusión de la Reforma de
las pensiones Tendría que ir en paralelo
a un debate
sincero sobre la inmigración es decir yo
creo que las dos cosas van van un poco
de la mano o sea es un Francia como
otros países de Europa necesita mucha
mano de obra en este para muchos
sectores
el sistema de pensiones se hará
sostenible evidentemente Si la gente
trabaja más pero si hay más personas
cotizando entonces ahí entra lo de la
inmigración que es un tema explosivo en
este país
propicio al populismo pero que deberían
ser valientes suficientemente valientes
para abordar que habría que traer
inmigración controlada selectiva y
aumentar la población activa Y eso sería
contribuiría a sostener el sistema de
pensiones y ese debate no se hace y todo
esto en un contexto Bueno pues de crisis
energética de forma general el fenómeno
de la crisis energética es más grave
Cuanto más dependencia energética padece
un país eso solo lo estamos viendo
claramente estos días ya hago esta
crisis va a establecer una antes y un
después en la importancia de ser
autosuficientes como la covilo fue en
otros temas quizá Esa es la gran
enseñanza que vamos a sacar de esta
crisis hombre sin duda un problema y el
mayor problema es la dependencia que
teníamos del gas ruso había países como
Polonia que debería exclusivamente los
bálticos en el caso de Francia no ha
pasado con el gas pero pasa a nivel
eléctrico con las nucleares y nos
estamos dando cuenta como han dicho
estudiantes que tener la mitad de la
flota parada o sea te puede pasar no es
una cosa no es una locura Y que haces
entonces es verdad que ahora los planes
de la comisión y también de todos los
miembros van por una línea de
diversificar del suministro para tener
una seguridad del mismo y al mismo
tiempo invertir mucho en energía
renovables que al final las energías
renovables te permiten ser
autosuficiente porque tú produces la
electricidad y no dependes de terceros
podemos entrar luego en el debate de la
compra de los paneles de problemas de
tierras raras de la cadena de suministro
pero una vez que tú lo tienes instalado
dependes de terceros Entonces se va por
la línea de tener Independencia
energética de producción propia de
electricidad con renovables y también de
diversificar lo que no podemos producir
nosotros Oye por cierto eusebio estos
días hablar de plan de sobriedad es todo
el rato hablamos de planes de seguridad
austeridad ahorro energético ha tenido
que llegar Putin con su guerra para
plantearnos toda esta realidad y en
cambio llevamos tantos años hablando Ya
de calentamiento climático
porque no tenéis la sensación de que ha
tenido que llegar una explosión algo un
una chispa que encienda todo este debate
cuando debería haber sido normal estar
hablando de esto
pero lamentablemente el ser humano
estamos acostumbrados en occidente a un
ritmo de vida a un estilo de vida que
cuesta mucho de cambiar no es decir no
es la primera Crisis que hay o sea hubo
la crisis en los años 70 cuando el shock
petrolero que en fin yo me acuerdo
porque para acordarme que en Estados
Unidos pues se prohibió la circulación
por las autopistas en cuando Carter era
presidente una cosa inaudita en un país
como Estados Unidos no pero se sintió la
necesidad de tomar medidas drásticas
pero después los precios se
regularizaron y a la vida continúa
normal yo creo que existe el peligro de
que ahora con la crisis de Ucrania
quizás Ojalá la guerra dure poco hay
algún tipo de cambio en Rusia y vuelva
el flujo de gas y aquí no ha pasado nada
y es verdad que por otros motivos
motivos medioambientales tendrían que
tomarse medidas y una concienciación
profunda de la gente vea Sí el otro día
estuve acompañando a monos jóvenes aquí
aquí en París que se dedican a pagar los
escaparates de las tiendas que se quedan
encendidos durante la noche y una de
ellas me decía es que hemos nos hemos
acostumbrado a ver todos los escaparates
en durante la noche Pero quién va a
haber Quién va a ver esos escaparates de
una A las 6 de la mañana Quiero ver pero
bueno para esa generación como para
nosotros incluso que hemos crecido así
nos parece normal no entonces son cosas
así que dentro de unos años diremos que
burradas hacíamos verdad es como lo de
fumar en un interior que hasta que no
pasa un tiempo y no miras para atrás y
no gente de mi generación pero se podía
fumar en una redacción de periodistas y
te quedas como absolutamente pero se
pudiera la normalidad seguramente nos
pase lo mismo con esto verdad sí yo creo
que sí que nos daremos cuenta de Qué
cosas que borradas cosas que hacemos
ahora que hemos como puede ser no como
esto de las luces de los escapates que
es un ejemplo no las bolsas de
plásticomente
por suerte hay evoluciones positivas y
más allá de la coyuntura actual ya hago
la población mundial alcanzará 8.500
millones en 2030 Pero puede el planeta
suministrar la energía necesaria esto
las predicciones de hecho la agencia
Internacional de la energía me dice que
la población crece y el consumo de
Electricidad y de energía de crece
porque se habla de una magnitud que es
intensidad energética que es la cantidad
de energía que consumes por persona
Entonces estamos abocados a ser más
eficientes y consumir menos por persona
porque si consumimos lo mismo que
consumimos ahora y encima de una forma
no sostenible y no verde no damos Pero
es verdad que con los con el escenario
existente y en los escenarios que
presenta tanto la agencia Internacional
de la energía como el ipfc es posible
llegar a suministrar electricidad de
forma sostenible a la población que va a
ir aumentando por cierto no hay
políticamente ya para terminar un cierto
aire de optimismo en las cancillerías
occidentales respecto a que Putin pueda
perder esta guerra como si ya
estuviéramos
cantando Victoria en occidente respecto
al final de Putin como ven el ambiente
yo es muy interesante Francia como
observatorio porque hay muchos
inmigrantes refugiados intelectuales y
yo estoy detectando una cierta Euforia
los últimos días por los avances de
Ucrania por este caos de las
repeticiones del ejército ruso quizás
sea prematuro o quizás no yo creo que
existe la posibilidad de que algo ocurra
en los próximos próximas semanas o meses
que cambie por completo esta ecuación
podría ser pero sobre todo por lo
impensable que puede ser cualquier gesto
de Putin porque se complique más todavía
o sea las cosas que se cumplieron y la
amenaza nuclear hablar tanto de La
amenaza nuclear que es una cosa muy muy
gorda y pero claro
lo que pasa por la cabeza de Putin
pues muchísimas gracias Yago Beatriz
eusebio ha sido un placer tenerles hoy
en el programa llegamos al final nos
despedimos hasta la próxima semana aquí
en Primera Plana de radio Francia
internacional y de France 24 Muchísimas
gracias
[Música]